I'm by some hair bleacher report and
this is fixed of franchise I can't hate
on Brooklyn but it's always gonna be in
next town
first of all we play at the garden all
right don't forget that it's just iconic
you know what I mean its iconic those
colors the garden man like you know so
many moments you need the slightest
moment like I remember when t-mac had
that wild game and it was like we won
the chick you know I remember when
sanity and it was like we won the chips
I can't imagine it's we actually did win
the [ __ ] first thing I would do is beg
Dolan to sell the team that's my
personal y ou cuz you know like how
we've been the past two decades you know
I mean go be a rock star or play in your
band
go tour the world go live your dreams
you know stop crushing hours bro
if Dolan needs a feature for me I got
him we had a 16 forum I got a I got a
hook I got a bridge I'll do his ad-libs
I sing some harmony you know I mean
whatever you need my people go why was
Jim I would really I want to build this
young Court they said there's some
promise you know I mean shout out to
Dennis Knox RJ swap man there's a lot to
work with Lonzo Dotson I feel like we
got a like a goodie on court they just
got to develop you gotta admit you gotta
get more confidence more playing time
you know you got to put some beds around
them but you can't overpay for it we
kind of been known to do that as of late
and it hasn't
working out to your course but yeah I
think our young core got it that thing
you'd be foolish not to graphing honest
young too much a point for these you
know I mean you just got you could build
a whole team around him I'd love to see
him in that orange and blue for sure if
we keep developing this core januzaj he
could be a centerpiece think Bradley
bill would be dope new coming in just
knock down his you know some offense you
know Brian kind of broke our hearts and
on I really thought we're gonna not in
the decision right 2010 um I thought
that was gonna be us man but you know
we'll give it another shot 2021 what how
old a bronzy 36 I take it okay okay come
on Brian
we'll take it why my store the next fan
magazine switch sides for nothing me I'm
from New York
good boy boss man I just fixed the
Knicks cut the check I'm here hit my
line his dream Ville with range of the
treatments three out now deep